good morning strange loop my name is
Stuart Holloway thanks for having me I'm
really excited to be here and I'm gonna
be talking about closure spec and
specifically about agility and
robustness in programming and how close
respect can help with that and I want to
start with a very brief background of
the things that worry that I worry about
everyday that shape to some degree the
characteristics of spec and why I want
to use it I'm the founder of a
consulting company cognate echt
originally relevance that's since 2003
so I have 13 years of building systems
for other people and you know moving
from project to project I've been a
closure committer since closure 1
oh and so I have had you know
responsibility for a substantial open
source project I'm also a developer on
the atomic database so it's commercial
product development so a lot of
different you know kinds of software
development I also run the support team
at cognate echt so I get to really eat
my dog food when we make software you
know whether it's consulting or open
source or product software and it's not
working out great for people I am where
the buck stops and we get to hear about
it so which shapes your life a lot you
know compared to my early days as a
consultant where you just write your
software and then you get to walk away
and somebody else has to worry about it
and I'm also responsible for operations
for a lot of cloud software and so these
things combine to have n'cole cated in
me a real life cycle view of software
that includes everything from you know
before ideation - you know maintenance
and you know working on a really
brownfield and so when I think about
these things I want a lot of different
things and I'm going to talk about three
of them today I want programs that are
correct
I want systems that are correct that are
free from error I want to be agile I
want to be able to move quickly and
easily modifying systems changing them
to meet needs and I want my systems to
be robust
I want them to be able to withstand
adverse conditions and as an industry we
have a lot of techniques and language
for level practices and other kinds of
things that help us do this and I can't
cover them all today but just a sampling
of some that have been important to me
you see a lot of people using type
systems or example based testing which a
lot of people start with calling unit
testing to try to ensure that their
programs are correct to be agile
requires a lot of different things some
people leverage encapsulation so I know
that I can make a change over here and
it's not going to cause you know the
lights to turn off on that side of the
building because those systems are
encapsulated from each other now people
also rely on IDE s that can automate
refactoring so you can take a large and
complicated code base and move it
without having to touch tens of
thousands of lines of code yourself and
people also have come increasingly and I
think correctly to value what I'm going
to call local concision which is that
you know at the micro level when you're
working on a specific problem you can
answer that problem in three lines of
code or one line of code instead of 30
lines of code you know spread across ten
modules and if anybody like me worked
with the first versions of Java's
enterprise javabeans you'll know exactly
what I'm talking about when you want to
have local concision in order to be
agile robustness is a little bit more of
a greenfield for us as software
developers so I'm not going to sort of
lay down establish practices here but
you see people doing things like chaos
engineering and fuzz testing and
simulation testing and generative
testing but I think you know we have a
lot of room to think about those things
a closure as a language does not change
all of that right closure programmers do
not say you know don't want tests don't
want types don't want those things but
closure adds a particular spin that
helps out in all of these areas in terms
of correctness closure encourages
programming with pure functions and
closure also has a distinctive model for
state called the unified update model
in some circles and a model for flow
with channels and so these are all
things that help you write correctly you
know out the door they help you write
small things that you can compose about
and reason about fragility closures real
buzzword is simplicity if you make
simple things you will be able to take
the Legos and recombine them a different
way
whereas if everything is all fused
together you get stuck and then you know
at the language level there's not
necessarily a huge amount of help for
robustness but immutable data makes a
big difference if you know that the data
in your system never changes it's much
easier to walk up to a system that's in
trouble and figure out what's going on
and I actually think this is probably
the stealth advantage of functional
programming wearing my ops hat is being
able to walk up to a system and say
we're in big trouble here but I know
that ninety ninety-five percent of the
information in the system is just
sitting there in RAM and never changes
because it's immutable so I can
immediately rule out the class of
problems that come from well when I
looked at it a minute ago it was like
this and if I come back and look at it
again it's going to be different so and
then I have this other term here which
I've put in all three rows and I'm about
to define or characterized at least
which is systemic generality and so the
idea with systemic generality is that
all domains use the same general purpose
data structures we're in a lot of
languages you would make up a new type
or make up a new class or a new object
to represent every entity in the system
closure encourages you to represent
entities as for example maps or
dictionaries and so you might walk up to
a system written in C sharp or Ruby and
find hundreds of classes representing
different things in your domain and in
closure you're gonna find one class and
you don't even see it as a class right
you're gonna find maps and you're gonna
program with them and the advantage of
this is really summed up by the perlis
quote which is it was better to have a
large number of
functions that all work on a single data
type then to have a lot of disparate
functions that work on specific data
types and enclosure this generality is
extended by being systemic so when you
write closure programs you have the
ability to use these generic data
structures everywhere you can use them
in your code but you can also use them
in your configuration files which could
be written in Eden you can use them on
the wire with Eden or with freshen you
can use them in your durable store and
so what this does is it gives you the
ability to write really small code and
work in a very general way and have the
algorithms that do that job be much
better vetted because there's a small
number of them right that's kind of a
downstream consequence that people don't
necessarily immediately think about so
you have instead of having 10,000
different functions in your system you
have a hundred if you have a hundred you
can spend a lot more time making sure
those 100 functions are correct you can
make a lot spend a lot more time making
sure those 100 functions are fast and
then doing this across the system means
that you don't have to have toll booths
everywhere in your system where you're
crossing a boundary from is this my code
is this my configuration I mean how many
people have written something that
they're totally happy with from a unit
testing perspective or from a static
typing perspective and then it falls
over in production because there's
something busted in an XML file
somewhere or if something shows up in a
bit of JSON that you didn't expect so
taking the systemic approach is really
valuable and you know closures been
around for over a decade now and so we
have some experience reports with what
it's like to program like this and the
fact of it is it's pretty good right
people say great things this is a quote
that's been used in you know closure
talks before talking about developers
the very best programmers are producing
amazing things and they're doing so
really quickly so this is great and if
it were 2015 I would stop right now and
we could all hang out for a little bit
just chat and get to know each other or
we could dig in and do a deep dive into
the stuff that I just talked about talk
about functional programming or
immutable data
systemic generality but I want to do
something totally different today which
is talk about a problem that eats at the
conscience of closure development
developers and that problem is that this
systemic generality idea is fantastic
except that we all work with specificity
right when you sit down to actually work
in your domain you're actually thinking
about addresses or order items or models
of the human body or models of equipment
on a factory floor they're actually
specific things and so the closure
promises you know your life is going to
be better if you talk about those
specific things in a really general way
and so what happens is people have to be
disciplined in how they think about
specificity right closure doesn't have
specificity as a language objection
objective it's kind of the opposite and
so thinking about specific things is you
know on you and people go through two
phases with that if you're an outsider
to closure especially if you come from a
world of static typing it's just
downright scary right everything that
you look at in your traditional programs
that you're used to writing that shows
you how this domain is different from
that domain and what's interesting about
your domains appears to be gone
enclosure right in the name of this
generality then you use closure for a
while and you come to conclude that this
is very powerful in its delivering
assistance not perfection but assistance
on writing correct programs and being
agile and writing robust programs and so
then you start to sort of justify
closure to your friends as a winning
trade-off right we had to you know lose
our ability to talk about specificity
and we get this trade-off and it is a
clear win right you know it's it's you
know five ounces of win and one ounce of
pain or you know you'll come up with
your own you know numeric scoring system
but it seems like it's a big win and
what I want to do is take the next step
and say there's a way to approach this
where this doesn't have to feel like a
trade-off where it's all winning and so
you can program in the most generic way
possible and still still deal
with the specifics and that's what close
respect does closure spec is a standard
powerful integrated system enclosure for
specification and testing of your
systems and so this really answers the
challenge of how do I program
generically and talk about specific
things and it answers it by saying not
you have to be specific everywhere which
is what static typing and
object-oriented programming sort of the
direction that they take you but saying
that you can be specific in an ala carte
way sort of right running alongside your
actual code sort of separate place and
you can do this without sacrificing
generality and then you can leverage the
specificity at your discretion so it's
an entirely opt-in proposition there's a
bunch of different things that you can
do with spec or you can do know things
with spec or you can not like spec and
keep programming closure without spec
and spec won't care right the bits are
really insensitive their feelings will
not be hurt if you choose not to use
them and so when you think about closure
and spec together you get a ton of new
power that helps with these objectives
that I have because you have a way to do
declarative specification it's easier to
look at a system and sort of convince
yourself that you're moving in the
direction of having it work correctly
also you can automatically test your
system with closure spec so when you
write your specs
you don't write tests and spec writes
your tests for you if you've ever spent
time maintaining a test suite you should
be very intrigued right now also it
allows you to instrument existing code
at development time so you can say I
want to run in a development mode where
I enforce you know arbitrarily more
complex programmatic validations of data
and functions and you can turn that on
and you can turn it on a little bit
right you can turn it to four or you can
turn it all the way up to eleven you can
actually call instrument all which would
instrument every single symbol in your
system that had a spec on the agility
side a lot of being agile is being able
to walk up to your system and understand
it and manipulate it
and spec gives you several things here
gives you documentation so it adds to
documentation automatically it gives you
explanation so when you have a piece of
data or a function that you've used
incorrectly spec will tell you what is
incorrect about that use which is right
you know you could sort of put that
under the rubric good error messages on
the other side of that though spec also
provides conformance and what
conformance lets you do is say don't
tell me how my data was wrong tell me
how it was right and so conformance
allows you to get information about the
ways in which the data conforms to your
domain and oftentimes you're gonna have
and we'll see some examples you know
data that could be conformant to your
needs in more than one way suspect helps
you understand what went wrong it also
helps you understand what went right and
when you spec something closure can
generate example data for you so you
know there are a few people in the world
rich Hickey for example who think only
in the abstract at all times and you
know never actually touch keyboards and
just manipulate things with their mind
but most of us benefit from examples and
so one of the things that's fun about
developing with spec is as soon as
you've made a spec and it can even be a
very rudimentary one you can then say
give me example data or give me example
functions that do this
finally the tools that spec provides can
be available anytime so they're not
available only at compile time like type
checking they're not available only at
test time like a test suite and so you
can have the same smarts that you use to
understand how your system is put
together in effect at layer boundaries
at runtime without writing new code I
mean how many of you have had the
experience of you know having individual
modules work pretty pretty well but have
to go and write a whole bunch of special
stuff at the edges just to make sure
that things are happy now a lot of that
you get a lot of leverage for doing that
with spec because once you've written
the spec you can use the spec for that
job so you're going to compare this to
testing and static typing and Twitter is
going to have fun with it and so here's
your controversy slide color coding and
all
we'll spend a few minutes on this and
then we will look at the actual use of
speck and look at some code so
expressivity testing is very expressive
because if you have the arbitrary power
of your language at your disposal right
it's expressive as your languages type
systems vary greatly in expressivity a
lot of Industry code is written in
things like Java and c-sharp which are
not very expressive and then people do
cooler stuff with you know Haskell or
liquid Haskell or Idris but on balance
you know type systems have varying
expressivity and they certainly don't
express things that you only know at
runtime because they don't you know sort
of play at that time spec is written in
arbitrary closure code so it has
arbitrary X passivity just like testing
does example tests really allow you to
aspire to stakeholder correctness right
is it correct in the sense that the
person that paid me to write it is happy
and spec also does that type systems you
know are gradually moving in this
direction but if type systems actually
solve this problem then as soon as it
compiled everybody's job would be over
and statically type systems wouldn't
have bug databases right because we
would know that static type correctness
was equivalent to everybody was happy
and we could just move on clearly not
true testing tends not to be integrated
in the language there are a couple of
more recent languages that really do
integrate testing approach at the
language level but for the most part we
use testing tools that are sort of
add-on types are definitely integrative
in your language so in fact they're kind
of two integrated and so you know cool
work is happening now to sort of have
types be less integrated with your
language so you can sort of opt-in and
opt-out of them but generally the actual
industry experience with types is you
have to flow them around everywhere and
so you do something over here which
causes a type problem over here which
cascades over here and now you're over
here and that's called the X shape so
specs are integrated but they're
integrated dynamically so you can you
know adopt them to the degree that you
want and where you want example tests
are not specifications right they're not
they tend to be sort of ad hoc things
types very much our specifications right
type systems are
specifications although they're static
in nature and spec is obviously
specification because we named it that
so it has to be right but they are
specifications and because they are
dynamic because they exist in the
runtime of your code you can do sort of
what you want to with them so testing
with writing test by hand is writing
tests by hand
it's my use of the word manual in the
table right if you're writing tests by
hand that's what you're doing and then
you have to babysit those tests and you
have to keep them working or comment
them out or walk up to an existing
system where the test suite has 300
tests that are still passing in a
thousand that are not and you know try
to figure out what to do about that type
systems actually can be used to generate
tests but that's pretty rare so that's
that's a column where type systems you
know as used in industry it could really
you know take off you could actually use
types to say given these types
I want to automatically generate
examples from these types and and test
from them so that happens some it could
happen more and the spec it's the
default all right you write specs and
you can get generative tests for you
based on those specs so testing is
promoted for agility but when you take a
systemic view of testing for agility
it's very expensive because you know
that you end up having to write a
cascading set of tests right you have to
write small tests you have to write
medium-size tests you have to write
tests that cover the boundaries you find
redundancies in the work that you're
doing and so tests do help with agility
I'm certainly not going to argue that we
should stop writing example based tests
tomorrow but they're expensive to
maintain
type systems as they're used are fragile
because of over specification and this
goes back to the point about the general
versus the specific if you say really
specific things all over your codebase
then when you change something that
causes a pachinko effect where things
are sort of bounced around through the
codebase and you have to sort of update
that with spec you can spec as much as
you want or as little as you want and
you can enforce a la carte so
enforcement is entirely separate from
making the statements to begin with and
then reach again example tests can reach
everywhere you could write unit tests
the test here
the mail configuration file but it's
expensive right people tend to focus
testing on certain parts of their system
and you know less energy in other places
type systems tend to reach only the code
parts of your systems you don't have
type systems on wires or in storage or
in configuration files and things like
that
and of course because spec is built on
top of closure it has that kind of reach
so if you're coming for the why do I
care we're now done this is this is why
this slide is really why we built spec
and what we were trying to do with it
and then I'm going to use the next 20
minutes to talk about you know show you
some code and show you what it looks
like using it so having written specs
what kinds of things can you get help
with well you can find out what are the
building blocks of my system because you
have this declarative specification you
can ask what invariants hold about data
or about functions you can say make
checks for that and turn those on
validation you can get detailed
explanations of what went wrong you can
get detailed explanations of what went
right you get automatic documentation
you get automatic example generation you
get the ability to turn on
instrumentation inspect functions in
development time this is a development
time feature need to emphasize that turn
on instrumentation that allows you to do
small medium or large and complex
validations of your function calls and
making sure that they're being called
correctly on the other side you can make
sure that your functions are implemented
correctly by using automatic generative
testing and then you can leave
assertions in your production system
that leverage this same thing so you
know unlike with types and with tests
which tend to be kind of gone well you
know once you're in production these
things are still there and you can opt
in to the exact amount of sort of
protection you want now in order to see
all this you have to know closure and in
a long-standing strange loop tradition
I'm just going to assume you know
closure and skip past these slides I'm
gonna give this talk in other
environments later but for now I'm just
going to assume you know closure because
we got a lot to cover and we're going to
talk about the actual building blocks
here so we're gonna start with
you know what does it mean to make a
specification well if you're a closure
programmer you already know how to make
specifications because all the
predicates in closure our specs and so
these predicates cover things that you
might think of as like primitive like if
you're looking at it from a Java
language perspective so things like a
mile long or a Maya double they also
cover things that are class like so
things that are like a Maya ratio or a
string or a UUID but it also includes
predicates that cross cut things that
the Java type system underneath closure
doesn't anything about so you can say am
I a rational number which is actually
the union of types that don't have a
type relationship between them but it
goes further than this you know any
arbitrary predicate can act a suspect so
predicate sar not limited to talking
about the shape of things they can also
talk about the runtime values that they
have so you can have a spec that says
something is something a specific value
like true or false or in the set 0 1 & 2
you can talk about the ranges of things
so is this a positive integer is this a
negative integer and really you can talk
about arbitrary runtime facts maybe if
you can write a function that takes an
argument and returns true or false
you're now participating in spec right
you can write your own predicate and
that predicate is now expect and you can
use it in all these ways in your system
of course we have collections and there
is a rich set of support for collections
but just to give you a little bit of a
flavor of it you can say just what's in
my collection so call of string is this
is a collection that needs to be full of
strings and strings only and then
there's a lot of bells and whistles so
you can say I have a collection of
integers but that collection has to be
of a vector shape and there have to be
at least 5 integers men count 5 but
there can't be more than 10 so max count
of 10 and by the way all the integers
are distinct all right so the integer 2
can't appear in there again you can have
heterogeneous tuples so this is a you
know a pain point sometimes in languages
like Java where you really want kind of
these generic things you can just walk
up and say ok this thing is an INT
followed by an INT followed by a keyword
and of course everything composes so you
can say I want to make a map of keywords
to collections of integers so this might
be you know
all of the different characters in a
game and then their scores or who knows
spec also has boolean operators and and
or so you can say more than one thing
has to be true about a piece of thing
you can say this thing has to be a
string but this is a string that
represents a SKU and my catalog system
so it's a string but it also has to
start with SKU - or you can have an or
so here we have a system where imagine
that people can identify themselves
either by their assigned numeric ID or
by their email you can say that a
person's identifier is either a positive
integer or a string now once you start
making these compositions in more
elaborate specs you very quickly want to
have named specs all right you want them
to be a first-class thing in the
language so you can give them names so
the deaf form allows you to give specs
names and you can say things like my app
/ SKU is a string that starts with skew
and purchaser is someone who has either
an account ID which is an int or an
email which is a string and now I'm
going to be processing a CSV file so I'm
gonna use specs to describe an existence
existing CSV file out in the world which
has three columns in it it has a
purchaser which could be that integer or
string it has the SKU which has to be a
string that starts with SKU and a
positive integer which is the number of
things of that SKU that that purchaser
purchased or whatever and the the names
here are global names so these are
namespace names the double colon
enclosure here's your one little closure
tidbit for the day double colon closure
is such a shorthand for in the current
namespace so this code is all running in
the my app namespace so my app /q
could also be double colon SKU and so
the important thing there is that when
you have named specs then we can share
specs across projects right you can
build a spec that's composed of some
specs that I wrote and some specs that
are in closure and all of those things
can work together because we're not
gonna have any name collisions specs can
also talk about syntax so syntax is from
the Greek it's about the ordering of
things and if you're not actually a
language implementer you don't spend a
lot of time necessary
thinking about the amount of time we as
humans are using order to get meaning
out of something and so spec has a
integrated regular expression library
it has catenation so this comes an order
followed by that followed by that it has
alternatives
so the alt form says you know at this
point and the syntax you could have this
or you could have an at it has all the
things you expect to have in regular
expressions but these are not regular
expressions of strings these are regular
expressions of arbitrary data so this is
more like the computer science regular
expressions than like the Perl regular
expressions that your might think of
first when you hear that word and so
when you think about what that looks
like you can now start to spec all the
forms in the language itself so this is
a very small closure program that
defines a function called greet that
takes an argument called your name and
then returns a string which is Hello
followed by your name
well the spec for that is a catenation
of the name which has to be a simple
symbol followed by a doc string which is
optional so notice the question mark
there the doc string is optional
followed by some metadata well I don't
even have any metadata in this example
so that was also optional and then the
body part is actually quite complicated
and so you're taking advantage here of
the fact that you can have name spects
so the bees their name body or bodies
that thing is some complicated spec that
describes what the shape of the
internals of a closure function are you
can spec maps as information and this
slide is essentially the replacement for
oo right when you think of oo as sort of
encapsulation and entities and getters
and setters and things like this so this
is saying I'm going to talk about a map
but I'm gonna make you make a new thing
right you're gonna keep passing maps
around your program and when you want to
be specific you're not gonna stop using
Maps you're just going to talk about
your Maps somewhere else with a spec
like this and this spec says and you can
imagine that this is a spec for you know
an address book entry that an address
book entry consists of a name and a
street and a city and the state and the
zip and optionally a street to
critically here this spec does not say
what the shape of street or city or
those things are specified elsewhere
which means this whole system composes
you can take this and I don't even have
to know what those things are in fact
those specs don't have to exist right
you can absolutely use name specs that
don't exist up until the point where you
have to you know program against them
and do something that wants them to
exist but just talking about things you
can talk about things and they don't
even have to exist yet so you can sort
of build this in any order so that's all
about specking data but you can also
spec functions so when you spec a
function well what is a function a
function takes a list of arguments well
that's ordering so that's syntax and a
function returns something that's a
return value so here I have a function
called index of that takes a string and
something you're searching for and maybe
a start position and you can spec that
as a function you can say well the args
for index of are a catenation right any
argument list our function is a regular
expression that's a catenation of its
arguments it's a string it's an
alternative of either a string or care
and then optionally a start position and
then the return is Anila both natural
int so my index of returns the position
of something that it found or if it
didn't find the thing it returns nil so
this is pretty cool right this allows
you not to just talk about data but to
talk about functions but where it gets
insanely cool is when you add the third
element two functions which are semantic
specifications so what are the semantics
of a function the semantics of a
function are the relationship between
its arguments and its return value this
is fundamentally a dynamic thing right
you have to run the function to see and
in this case I'm going to specify that
index of has to categoric outcomes
either I can find something or I can not
find it because I have the or form I can
give those things names and then I could
say what each of those looks like well
if it's not found the return had better
be nil and if it is found the return had
better be less than or equal to the size
of the search string right that is a
runtime thing so the search string
happened to have 30 characters in it if
index I've returned 50 that's a buggy
implementation right that couldn't
possibly be true so these are predicates
of the actual behavior of the system now
notice at this point that I have given
you a
painfully whirlwind tour of a bunch of
different things that you can say with
speck but I haven't actually said what
happens in your program when you say all
these things and the answer is nothing
you say all those things and now you
have you know a set of you know
descriptions of data and your system
sitting on your shelf and you can do
stuff with those descriptions when can
you do stuff with those descriptions it
is absolutely up to you which of the
things do you want to do with those
descriptions it's also absolutely up to
you so we're gonna dive in and take a
look at them so we'll start with
validation so validation is through a
call called valid so valid takes a spec
and then some data and it returns a
boolean telling you whether or not that
data matches the spec so here I have a
collection with ABC and oops and one of
those things is not like the others
right oops is not a keyword so valid
returns false now like most boolean
functions valid cuts the universe in
half but it's not very exciting to look
at on a slide it's not a whole lot going
on there so what you want to know is not
just you know that you're wrong but what
went wrong so you can also say explain
to me the way in which this data does
not match my spec when you ask for an
explanation you get what was wrong the
value oops was the problem a B and C
were fine you get how it was wrong the
predicate was keyword which you didn't
match you get what position it was wrong
at it's at position three zero one two
three
we're zero-based by some weird tradition
that started in the 70s so now you have
a detailed and precise pointer to where
your problem happened and by the way
this detailed and precise pointer this
is all compositional so if you have you
know the JSON ball of mud from hell
that's got something wrong with it you
know 17 layers deep in that thing then
you're gonna have a path through that
thing and a thing pointing you exactly
where the problem happened so it's nice
to know how things went wrong but you
might also want to know how things went
right so you can say conform conform
takes a spec and some data in this case
this data is actually program code and
it tells you and you can follow the read
here the red line it tells you how the
value matched
well the symbol your name was in the
bees branch of the or it was in the air
D one branch of another or it was in the
args branch of the args branch with a
sim ranch every one of those five things
in red represents a point at which this
thing could have been a valid function
but it looks different right and the
spec for defin is a pretty rich thing
right there's a lot of different things
that happen that are legal in defin so
it's a complicated spec and conformance
gives you the ability to say exactly how
does this data conform this by the way
also gets rid of a ton of ad hoc parsing
in your own program right if you're
having to interpret something that's
ordered the first thing that you want to
do is often give names to that order
well spec gives names to that order and
then you can call it on an ala carte
basis if you're an experienced closure
programmer think of this as D
structuring on steroids
right this is data-driven destructuring
where you can drive the restructuring
sort of anywhere you want
of course you get documentation and
example data so having SPECT that letter
grade is a function that takes a numeric
grade and returns one of the letters a B
C D F then in the documentation string
you get aspect addendum section that
says you know here's what this is I have
found that a lot of times once I starts
pecking functions I don't actually put
anything else in the docs string right I
just let the doc string get the little
spec addendum and that's all I need to
know you can also get sample data so you
can say well I know that a grade I'm
gonna define that a grade is a number
it's this American at least the grading
system I have when I was in high school
a grade is a number between 0 and 100
and then I could say exercise grade for
me when you ask closure to exercise a
spec it will generate examples that
conform to that spec and show you how
they conform so the reason that you see
pairs here is the first piece of data is
the data that it generated and the
second piece is how it conformed when
you're conforming as a number how it
conformed isn't very interesting right
because it can only do one thing so
there's nothing in that second value
that's interesting in that case you can
also if you expect a function exercise
that function so here there's some
function letter grade that takes a
numeric grade and returns a letter I
could say exercise this function for me
and spec can generate data that
represent inputs to the function call
the function for you as many times as
you want and then return the output that
results and you can eyeball the
Cinco yes well 94 should be an A then 60
should be a D you know if that all looks
pretty good well once you have this
ability to generate data including
function calls in your system you have
access to some powerful capabilities for
making your system more robust you can
instrument your system so here's a
scenario where I have a development time
switch that says start server is going
to be instrumented I don't even know how
it works and then I'm going to call it
I'm going to call it incorrectly it
turns out port default is not legal
when instrumentation is turned on I'm
gonna get a specific error that says
port was the problem that this spec
failed that the problem happened in this
line of this module of my program and
this is not a static thing this is a
running thing all right this is not you
know you run you you're limited to what
you can do at static time this is you're
running your program and you can turn
this you know you can turn this up to 11
and say you know something's going wrong
here I don't understand how this other
subsystem is using what I'm calling
maybe I'm not calling it correctly
similarly you can test automatically so
you can say please check this for me
when you ask spec to check something for
you it's gonna say generate an arbitrary
number of inputs until you get tired
I think the defaults 100 it's going to
invoke the function for you and then
it's going to check the return predicate
to make sure the thing is structurally
sound and then it's gonna check the
function predicate to make sure that the
things semantics are sound and if it
finds a problem it's going to shrink to
a small repo automat reaper before it
goes back to you so it's gonna find some
big hairy example that shows that your
program is broken and then it's going to
heuristic ilish wrink that down to a
tiny example so here it found a bug in a
buggy deliberately buggy program with a
really tiny argument set of the empty
string and the string 0 and of course
you have assertions where you can take
the same detailed error messages and
sprinkle them where you want to in your
production system so you don't put them
everywhere but maybe on certain
boundaries in your system or certain
internal places where you have
presumptions you can turn on assertion
you can leave assertions in your code if
check asserts is off there's no runtime
footprint so
in summary spec is about doubling down
on being a dynamic language
specification is a problem but you don't
need to be more static to solve it okay
specification is a dynamic idea it's
something that allows you to deliver
simple specifications separate from your
code and then pour in value invalidation
in error checking in conformance in
testing and add exactly the parts of
value that you want so where are we this
we're on closure alpha 12 of closure 1 9
so I've done we've done 12 alphas here I
expect we will go beta soon so this will
be beta soon people are already using it
in production but it is early days we
are eager to get people's experience
reports there's just a ton of really
cool stuff that people at Strange Loop
we're doing and we'd like to know you
know how it works with spec having said
that take advantage of the dynamic
nature of spec this is not an
all-or-nothing thing that you have to
jump into with both feet and do
everywhere try using little bits of it
here and little bits of it there be
thoughtful about the danger areas and
one danger area is definitely over
specification right spec has tried very
hard to be as dynamic as possible and as
flexible as possible and to not require
you to make overly specific statements
but you can make whatever statements you
want
it's a general-purpose programming
language so I predict you know five
years from now I'll have consulting work
going in and helping people make their
specs more general and and keep things
as general as they can so that's
definitely a challenge area also
generating data is there are a lot of
interesting things to explore there
which we don't have time to do today if
you want to learn more about closure
spec you can see the website closure org
about spec and I will be out on the hall
we don't have time for questions here
but I'll be out in the hall for the next
couple of hours and if you're interested
in talking more I'd love to hear from
you my name is Stuart Holloway and that
was closure spec thank you